[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit hanna zimmermann und christian
sieber
guten abend hinein es gibt gegen den in
der ukraine da gab es die dort so
beliebten traditionellen blumen präsente
heute am weltfrauentag
und sie haben tatsächlich ihre
empfängerinnen erreicht vom ehemann vom
liebhaber vom enkel in anderen teilen
des landes ist die situation verheerend
abschiedsszenen heute in einem vorort
von kiew während weiter russische panzer
vor würden menschen die durch
apokalyptische
trümmerlandschaften irren und versuchen
sich in sicherheit zu bringen nur für
wenige sind die flucht korridore einen
weg aus dem kriegsgebiet hier in sumy
schaffen sie es in den retten den bus
und welches bild sich bietet wenn man
heute durch die ukrainische hauptstadt
kiew fährt das zeigen wir ihnen jetzt
ahnt ginzel ist dort
heute nachmittag wir sind auf dem weg
nach kiew wenige kilometer vor der
ukrainischen hauptstadt wir kommen von
süden noch ist die stadt nicht
eingekesselt und die ukraine 10
streitkräfte zusammen doch der
gegenverkehr zeigt zig tausende sind auf
der flucht
frage
der verwaltung
immer wieder passieren der checkpoints
filmen ist eigentlich verboten manchmal
sind männer mit jagdgewehren zu sehen am
frühen abend erreichen wir kennen das
schon verrückt diese
straße zu sehen die fast leeres
normalerweise um die zeit sich 241 ist
die folge stau die leute kommen von der
arbeit aber heute ist hier so gut wie
ausgestorben
wenige minuten später der ort an dem der
russische angriff auf wohnblocks und
zivilisten getroffen hat in das hochhaus
hinter mir hat eine rakete eingeschlagen
schon ganz am anfang das waren so die
ersten attacken die russische armee
gegen kiew gerichtet hat das haus ist
leer
auch auf den straßen sieht man ganz
wenige menschen im augenblick dafür
haben wir schon auf der fahrt nach kiew
gesehen die menschen wollen raus die
wollen nur noch richtung westen die
wollen sich und ihre familien in
sicherheit bringen unterwegs zum
hauptbahnhof noch fahren offenbar züge
raus aus der stadt es ist kurz vor 6 in
knapp einer stunde beginnt die
ausgangssperre doch an den gleisen
gedränge
es sind vor allem frauen und kinder die
wir hier antreffen man sieht im prinzip
alles ist dunkel es ist abgedunkelt wie
die stadt das dient dem schutz damit
möchte man sozusagen
die stadt vor fliegerangriffen bewahren
am abend des 13 kriegs tages liegt der
meydan der platz der revolution im
dunkeln es wirkt wie die ruhe vor dem
sturm
es ist der achte märz weltfrauentag und
es ist krieg das ist zufall kein zufall
dass es gerade die frauen besonders
trifft mehr als zwei millionen menschen
sind mittlerweile in die nachbarländer
der ukraine geflüchtet die uno sagt so
etwas hat es seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
in europa nicht mehr gegeben die
hauptlast dabei tragen frauen die ihre
jobs zurück lassen ihre wohnungen ihre
männer die versuchen den kindern das
überleben zu sichern und dabei über sich
hinauswachsen patricia schäfer ist an
der grenze der ukraine zu ungarn
der bahnhof des ungarischen städtchens
saronni gleich hinter der grenze zur
ukraine
jeden moment sollen freunde von lena aus
kehrt hier ankommen mit drei kindern
zwischen zwei und 16 jahren das handy
halten sie lena auf dem laufenden
gestern war der zwölfte tag des krieges
und wir konnten es einfach nicht mehr
aushalten
die ganze zeit hat sie angst dass eine
bombe durch fenster fliegt oder wir
erschossen werden sie sind im job der
letzten stadt vor der ungarischen grenze
tausende menschen aus allen teilen der
ukraine warten wir auf die weiterfahrt
die mission aufs wollen nach ungarn und
weiter nach wien
wir hoffen dass wir nur auf einen kaffee
nach wien fahren und bald wieder
zurückkommen können
das hoffe ich gern mein kleiner
[Musik]
münster 34
übrigens kurz
seit vier stunden warten die mission
offs nun schon auf den zug auf dem nur
wenige kilometer entfernten bahnhof auf
ukrainischer seite so nah und doch so
fern diesen seit 24 stunden auf dem weg
es gibt massive wartezeiten niemand kam
rein und raus die müssen warten die
haben überhaupt keine ahnung hat sie den
zug erwischen können stunde um stunde
vergeht es ist ein quälendes warten die
kleinen seien nur noch am weinen erzählt
anna am telefon und schickt noch dieses
video
ich wollte gern kämpfen wie alle
soldaten der ukraine aber ich bin nicht
alt genug
deswegen musste ich leider weg fahren
auf meiner heimatstadt das tue ich auch
damit mein kleiner bruder keine bomben
hört
am ungarischen bahnhof steht inzwischen
ein mann der mitfahrgelegenheiten
anbietet vier mal ist er bereits hin und
her gefahren bringt frauen und kinder
die hier ankommen nach wien das wäre
genau was die familie mission noch
brauchen kann
sie ist auch so eine vertrauenssache die
meisten sind traumatisiert es sind fast
ausschließlich frauen und wenn dann typ
wie ich da steht aber die kriegen von
mir dann auch die telefon und man von
den anderen nur klein an dich schon gut
abgeliefert habe dann passt das wieder
endlich kommt der zug aus japan mehr als
vier stunden verspätet aber es dauerte
lange bis die passagiere aussteigen
können die grenzkontrolle findet im zug
statt nach einer dreiviertelstunde
können die mission los endlich
aussteigen erschöpft aber erleichtert
endlich in sicherheit wenn auch weit weg
von zu hause
dieser krieg ist grausam und erfordert
opfer beim militär und auch wenn
russlands regierung abstreitet
zivilisten ins visier zu nehmen unter
müttern vätern und ihren kindern deshalb
sind bilder wichtig als zeugnis dessen
was gerade geschieht in der ukraine als
beweis und als anklage auch wenn sie
kaum zu ertragen sind dazu gehört ein
bild das wir ihnen jetzt zeigen und sie
gleichzeitig warnen falls sie lieber
wegschauen möchten das bild geht um die
welt auf der titelseite der new york
times es zeigt ukrainische soldaten die
einer familie zur hilfe kommen nachdem
diese von einem russischen mörserangriff
getroffen wurde an einer brücke bei kiew
und dann feststellen sie können nichts
mehr tun eine mutter ihr sohn im
teenageralter und ihre tochter ungefähr
acht jahre alt getroffen getötet auf der
flucht
das bild hatte lynsey addario gemacht
kriegsfotografen an den schwierigsten
orten dieser welt pulitzer preisträgerin
für ihr werk und jetzt bei uns guten
abend nach kiew
guten abend frei darío können sie uns
mal die situation beschreiben bitte in
der sie da fotografiert haben sie waren
ja unmittelbar dabei
natürlich
ich bin seit drei wochen hier vor ort
und ich habe immer wieder gehört dass
leute über die brücke kommen
und ich bin sehr früh morgens dorthin
gegangen
ich dachte dass ich dort einfach
dokumentieren kann wie die leute über
die brücke kommen
wenige minuten danach habe ich 40
gesehen dass granaten abgeworfen wurden
ich dachte dass man zielt auf eine basis
des ukrainischen militärs das in der
nähe ist
das wurde auch dokumentiert von den
journalisten das ist das jetzt die route
ist für zivilisten zur evakuierung
klinische soldaten
die geholfen haben das gepäck zu tragen
haben wir gemerkt dass die immer näher
an die zivilisten kamen die dort
gelaufen
ich habe mich dort und wollte mich
schützen und jedes mal wenn ihr hoch
geschaut habe sah ich wieder etwas
dann habe ich wieder ein foto gemacht
und plötzlich sah ich kinder
dieser kinder
und sachen meter von mir entfernt wenn
nicht noch näher
dann sag ich dir familie eine
ukrainische familie
natürlich chaos in diesem moment
die sicherheitsleute
da ist diese familie eine frau und ihre
beiden kinder
und da dürften die noch einen freund der
familie der wollte die in die sicherheit
bringen begleiten
hatte diese familie die ja ganz klar auf
der flucht war ihre habseligkeiten mit
dabei hat hatte diese familie überhaupt
eine chance diesem bombardement zu
entgehen
hatte glück und kamen raus
die familie auf dem foto hat leider
nicht überlebt die mutter und die beiden
kinder haben es nicht überlebt vor dario
haben sie überlegt ob sie so eine
situation fotografieren sollten oder ob
sie so eine situation überhaupt
fotografieren dürfen
natürlich dass bin selbst mutter und
habe kinder
und ich habe szenen schon erlebt und
gesehen
und ich habe unser leblosen körper
gesehen die der kinder
es war ganz furchtbar ich dachte aber
auch dass dieses foto das zeugnis eines
kriegsverbrechens ist und da sich dieses
foto machen soll
diese menschen unschuldige zivilisten
wurden angegriffen
sie sagen kriegsverbrechen das zeugnis
eines kriegsverbrechens was sagt das was
sie gesehen haben über die behauptung
von wladimir putin zivilisten seien
keine ziele seiner seines krieges
ich denke
dass ich seit über 20 jahren als
kriegsreporterin arbeite
beschossen worden
ich war in gefährlichen situationen
viele schlimme dinge gesehen ich war
überall in der welt auch in afghanistan
schon tätig
aber das war eine situation
das ziel waren und die granaten die
wurden wirklich auf die zivilisten
geworfen das war das ziel die zivilisten
sagte ein cad rio fotoreporterin für die
new york times aktuell in der ukraine
frau dario herzlichen dank und alles
gute auch für sie
vielen dank
das gespräch haben wir am abend
aufgezeichnet die fotos von den stereo
dürften auch den generalbundesanwalt in
karlsruhe interessieren seine behörde
sammelt seit heute systematisch
informationen über mögliche russische
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine
die ermittler haben dafür so sagen sie
bereits konkrete anhaltspunkte und es
gibt strafanzeigen in denen gefordert
wird russlands präsidenten wladimir
putin zur verantwortung zu ziehen wie
aussichtsreich so etwas ist was es
bringt und was passiert wenn sich die
politik am ende mit ebendiesem putin
doch wieder an einen tisch setzen wird
bzw
muss dazu jetzt kann man es auf jahre an
und christoph schneider
die russische armee wird baum über
zivilisten und bewohntes gebiet ab ich
bin bei kiew
putins armee greift zivile ziele und
unbeteiligte an wie hier in einem
kindergarten in kharkiv
begeht russland in der ukraine
kriegsverbrechen sind gar geächtete
waffen wie streubomben
im einsatz
sie beschießen uns mit raketen
ballistischen raketen sie haben eine
vakuum bombe benutzt die von der genfer
konvention verboten ist
wer ist dann in den haag die ukraine hat
russland jetzt beim höchsten gericht der
vereinten nationen dem internationalen
gerichtshof verklagt der vorwurf
verletzung der völkermord konvention von
1948 auch der internationale
strafgerichtshof ebenfalls in den haag
hat ermittlungen zu kriegsverbrechen
gegen russland eingeleitet
völkerrechtler halten es für wichtig
russische kriegsverbrechen zu
dokumentieren
also nach dem was wir bisher wissen was
unter anderem auch durch
menschenrechtsorganisation dokumentiert
worden ist können wir durchaus
feststellen so denke ich dass es eine
gute grundlage dafür gibt diejenigen zur
verantwortung zu ziehen die für
kriegsverbrechen verantwortlich sind es
sind eine ganze reihe solcher
kriegsverbrechen dokumentiert etwa der
gezielte angriff auf zivile objekte und
das ist auch im bewaffneten konflikt
verboten und strafbar wegen möglicher
russischer kriegsverbrechen in der
ukraine ermittelt jetzt auch die
deutsche bundesanwaltschaft
sie hat ein sogenanntes struktur
ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet es gebe
konkrete anhaltspunkte für bereits
begangene kriegsverbrechen
ohne konkrete beschuldigte sollen mit
dem verfahren breit beweise gesichert
werden entscheidend dabei das
weltrechtsprinzip
kriegsverbrecher soll nirgendwo auf der
welt sicher sein und natürlich geht von
dem umstand dass ermittlungen in den
haag und in karlsruhe nun eingeleitet
worden sind auch ein wichtiges
symbolisches signal aus ein symbol
dahingehend dass diejenigen die solche
verbrechen begehen nicht sicher sein
können nicht doch in zukunft einmal zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden können doch
russlands verantwortliche sollten nicht
in die enge getrieben werden entgegnen
spitzendiplomaten sie fordern erst die
diplomatie dann die justiz
vor den strafgerichtshof gezerrt werden
aber bitte nicht andersrum das macht uns
die suche nach einer diplomatischen
ausweg nach ende des kriegs nur schwer
ein schwieriger balanceakt ein
sofortiges kriegsende mit putin
aushandeln und kriegsverbrechen zu
bestrafen
wenn wir die ölimporte aus russland
sofort einstellen würden dann werden wir
uns in deutschland nicht mehr
fortbewegen können sagt die deutsche
außenministerin heute die verteidigung
der freiheit hat ihren preis sagt der us
präsident heute und er lässt einen
importstopp für russisches öl damit ist
die situation bereits beschrieben zur
wahrheit gehört allerdings auch dass die
usa deutlich weniger auf öl aus russland
angewiesen sind als europa dass dieser
schritt ihnen also deutlich leichter
fällt als uns und das die eu gerade
merkt wie sehr sie in einer lose lose
situation steckt und wie dringend ein
notfallplan hermus aus brüssel florian
neumann
in der mappe für den us-präsidenten an
diesem tag steht an erster stelle mal
wieder eine neue sanktionen gegen
russland und dahinter anders als zuletzt
eine botschaft an alle die er damit auch
unter druck setzt die eigenen
verbündeten
ich verstehe dass viele unserer
europäischen verbündeten nicht in der
position sind uns zu folgen die usa
produziert selbst deutlich mehr öl als
alle europäischen staaten zusammen
die usa stoppen den import von
russischem öl und egal wie viel
verständnis der us präsident für
europäische nöte aufbringt die debatte
warum europa zwar ukrainische flaggen
vor dem parlament hilft aber hier nicht
mitzieht sie lässt sich nicht aufhalten
mit jedem kriegstag werden die kritiker
eindringlicher wir füttern mit unseren
öl und gasimporten die kriegsmaschine
putins ja das ist eine schizophrenie wir
liefern der ukraine ein bisschen waffen
und gleichzeitig finanzieren wir den
russischen sein kriegs apparat das ist
die haupteinnahmequelle
auftritt der eu kommission in straßburg
in der mappe von frans timmermans steht
nichts von neuen sanktionen weshalb der
eu klimakommissarin und wieder erklären
muss warum europa zögert
es wäre so gut in der politik wenn man
die zeit zurückdrehen und bessere
entscheidungen treffen
aber jetzt müssen wir mit dem
kartenspielen die uns aufgeteilt
was europa auf der hand hat ein
gasimport von zuletzt 45 prozent aus
russland mehr als du four darauf
komplett zu verzichten das wäre sagt die
kommission im winter ein echtes problem
bis ende dieses jahres aber will die den
import um zwei drittel reduzieren
zarti hat es ist verdammt
wenn wir bereit sind uns schneller und
weiter zu bewegen als bisher das gas
speicher wie zuletzt über monate auf
kritische unter 30 prozent leer laufen
soll nicht mehr passieren bis oktober
sollen die speicher zu 90 prozent
gefüllt sein müssen dann eben mit gas
von anderen lieferanten etwa den usa
oder katar außerdem will die kommission
erneuerbare energien massiv ausbauen und
sie hofft dass alle mitmachen beim
energiesparen für europa der narrative
ist die erzählung ist gut dass wir ziele
setzen auch über die genau wie das alles
erreichen er verweist die kommission
aufs pläne die erst im juni kommen die
haben es noch nicht geschafft schon ob
der teuro par hat ein ungünstiges blatt
in dieser krise und fragt sich ob wohl
ausreicht was in der grünen mappe so
still
mehr zu den verwerfungen auf dem
energiemarkt und was das für deutschland
heißt nachher von der börse bei dir
hanna aber erst bleibt mir noch moment
bei russlands krieg in der ukraine und
da gucken natürlich alle auf die
diplomatie und dabei interessanterweise
auch nach piggy ganz genau bisher hatte
sich china vor allem als verbündeter
russlands gezeigt jetzt will präsident
schien offenbar dabei helfen den ukraine
krieg auf diplomatischen weg zu lösen
und dabei eng mit deutschland und
frankreich zusammen arbeiten das ist das
ergebnis einer video schalte von
bundeskanzler scholz frankreichs
präsident makro und dem chinesischen
präsidenten
zudem seien alle drei länder einig darin
dass flucht korridore geschaffen werden
müssten das teilte regierungssprecher
hebestreit mit laut chinesischem
staatsfernsehen machte präsident in dem
gespräch außerdem seine sorge über die
negativen folgen der sanktionen für die
weltwirtschaft deutlich
polen will nach eigenen angaben seine
kampfflugzeuge vom typ mig 29 an die usa
liefern diese könnten dann dem
ukrainischen militär zur verfügung
gestellt werden hintergrund ist dass der
ukrainische präsident seelen ski die
vereinigten staaten um unterstützung bei
der beschaffung von kampfflugzeugen
gebeten hatte klinische piloten sind
allerdings für kampfflugzeuge aus
sowjetischer zeit ausgebildet dazu
gehören die mig 29 jets
und immer mehr menschen fliehen aus der
ukraine auch nach deutschland mehr als
64.000 menschen sind mittlerweile in der
bundesrepublik angekommen
das hat das bundesinnenministerium
mitgeteilt
die meisten geflüchteten kommen in
berlin an allein gestern sollen es
13.000 gewesen sein in hamburg werden
nun zum teil messehallen für die
unterbringung genutzt gleichzeitig wird
die forderung lauter dass der bund die
verteilung der geflüchteten stärker
koordinieren müsse
deutlich weniger ukraine hat dagegen
großbritannien aufgenommen laut
britischem innenministerium sind es
bisher lediglich 300 geflüchtete wegen
dieser zurückhaltung bei der aufnahme
ukrainischer flüchtlinge gerät die
britische regierung zunehmend in die
kritik am abend bat der ukrainische
präsident seelands die per video im
londoner unterhaus um mehr unterstützung
er erhoffte sich weitere sanktionen
gegen russland sowie dessen einstufung
als terroristischen staat zudem
erneuerte selensky seine forderung nach
einem flugverbot über der ukraine
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
und jenen auf der flucht helfen wollen
können sie spenden zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
und so fiel zunächst zu diesem thema
darf der verfassungsschutz die afg als
verdachtsfall einstufen die antwort auf
diese frage hat es in sich denn bei
einem verdachtsfall kann der
verfassungsschutz die partei wesentlich
intensiver überwachen etwa bestimmte e
mails mitlesen
die antwort auf die frage ist jetzt da
die afg hatte vor dem verwaltungsgericht
köln geklagt und sie lautet ja der
verfassungsschutz darf dass das gericht
sagt damit auch ja es gibt zitat
ausreichende tatsächliche anhaltspunkte
für verfassungsfeindliche bestrebungen
innerhalb der partei david gebhard und
saar attacke mit mehr dazu über 100
aktenordner material hat der
inlandsgeheimdienst
zusammengestellt um zu belegen dass hier
der vorsitzende einer partei kommt die
die demokratie gefährde die afg mit
parteichef kino copala gegen das
bundesamt für verfassungsschutz das am
abend vor dem verwaltungsgericht köln
ein sieg einfährt es ist vor allen
dingen heute ein sieg für die demokratie
in deutschland ein guter tag für die
demokratie in deutschland
denn mit dieser einstufung die jetzt
auch vom gericht bestätigt wurde
verdachtsfall können wir auch wieder
öffentlich darüber reden dass wir in der
afg bestrebungen sehen die gegen die
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
gerichtet sind ja und hat das urteil des
gerichts überrascht wir teilen die
auffassung des gerichtes nicht wir
werden jetzt die schriftliche
urteilsbegründung abwarten sorgt haben
prüfen inwieweit wir weitere schritte
gegen dieses urteil vorgehen werden
zahlreiche äußerungen von fdp vertretern
hatte der verfassungsschutz vor gericht
angeführt als beleg für pauschale
muslimen migranten oder
demokratiefeindlichkeit kopftuchmädchen
und alimentierte messer männer und
sonstige taugenichts auch aus einer chat
gruppe der fc bayern wird zitiert ohne
umsturz und revolution erreichen wir
hier keinen kurswechsel mehr die richter
haben heute ganz deutlich gesagt
gibt klare belege dafür dass es teil in
fd gibt die verfassungsfeindlich
menschenverachtend demokratiefeindlich
sind und dass es eine starke strömung in
der partei ist die sich durchsetzen
könnte als rechtsextremer verdachtsfall
eingestuften darf der
inlandsgeheimdienst nun mit
nachrichtendienstlichen mitteln
beobachten heißt e mails mitlesen
telefone abhören und v leute einsetzen
dass der verfassungsschutz diese partei
als verdachtsfall einstuft das ist ein
relevanter auch sicherheitspolitischer
vorgang und er wirft natürlich fragen
auf auch für den deutschen bundestag
selbst zum beispiel bei der geheimdienst
kontrolle wenn dieses urteil
letztinstanzlich bestätigt ist ist das
natürlich nicht möglich dass eine partei
die als verdachtsfall eingestuft ist
mitglied im parlamentarischen
kontrollgremium ist demokratie
verachtung der hang zum autoritären
spiegelt sich dieser tage mitunter auch
in äußerungen einiger fdp-vertreter die
putins propagandalügen für den
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff auf die
ukraine eins zu eins übernehmen
wie so oft in der geschichte dass der
angreifer nicht eigentlich aggressor ist
in der russland frage die iaaf die
derzeit im richtungsstreit und nun die
beobachtung die mitglieder der partei
vertrauen könnte angehörige der afd im
öffentlichen dienst werden es jetzt noch
schwerer haben hier wird es
einzelfallprüfungen geben ob eine
mitgliedschaft in der afd mit einem
verbleib im öffentlichen dienst zu
vereinbaren ist immerhin haben alle
beschäftigten im öffentlichen dienst
einen eid auf die verfassung abgelegt
erstmals wird eine gesamtpartei die
bundestag sitzt vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet im verdacht in der herzkammer
der demokratie diese zu bekämpfen
die großen verwerfungen auf dem
energiemarkt weltweit haben wir schon
ausführlich berichtet in dieser sendung
jetzt gucken wir auf die folgen für
deutschland mit hanna viele
ankündigungen und entscheidungen waren
das ja heute aus den usa großbritannien
und auch seitens der eu diese
nachrichten die auch investoren sehr
aufmerksam verfolgen fragen nach
märz an der frankfurter börse wir haben
die anleger darauf reagiert die anleger
halten sich nach wie vor bedeckt diese
angespannte politische lage die zeigt
sich auch am deutschen aktienmarkt hier
ist man bescheiden geworden und schon
froh wenn das minus nicht ganz so heftig
ausfällt der dax beendet den handel plus
minus null und steht am ende bei 12.000
832 punkten
energielos zeigt sich der dax wenn auch
alle anderen energiewerte seit
kriegsbeginn nur eine richtung kennen
und zwar die nach oben allen voran der
ölpreis er klettert seit dem 23
februar um 32 prozent noch steiler ist
der anstieg bei gas von den
gaslieferungen aus russland will sich
die eu ja unabhängiger machen der weg
hin zu alternativen energien kommt nun
wie es scheint mit doppelter
geschwindigkeit
und diese pläne freuen alle unternehmen
die auf erneuerbare energien
spezialisiert sind die aktien von
siemens energy dem photovoltaik
unternehmen sma solar und des
windturbinenherstellers nordex können
heute zwischen 6 und 15 prozent zulegen
noch vor ein paar tagen konnten alte
energieversorger punkten heute liegt das
plus dann eindeutig bei den erneuerbaren
denn der weg ist unumkehrbar gut
aufgestellt dürften künftig diejenigen
unternehmen sein die einen energiemix
aus alt und neu liefern können danke sie
nach frankfurt
am heutigen weltfrauentag sin
deutschlandweit tausende beschäftigte
von kitas und sozialen einrichtungen auf
die straße gegangen gewerkschaft verdi
hatte zu den warnstreiks und
kundgebungen aufgerufen und so den druck
in den laufenden tarifverhandlungen zu
erhöhen gefordert werden mehr lohn und
bessere arbeitsbedingungen
viele kitas blieben wegen der heutigen
streiks geschlossen
ab dem 20 märz fallen in deutschland die
meisten corona beschränkungen weg dann
soll ein neues infektionsschutzgesetz
gelten die beratungen dazu seien kurz
vor dem abschluss
das sagte heute
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
unter anderem soll es dann hot spot
regeln geben blicken wir außerdem auf
die korona zahlen die im wochenvergleich
weiter ansteigen so meldeten die
gesundheitsämter dem robert koch
institut heute
156 1799 neuinfektionen das sind über
34.000 mehr als vor einer woche die
sieben tage incidents steigt den
sechsten tag in folge und liegt nun bei
1.200 93,6
im osten australiens dauern die heftigen
regenfälle weiter an nun ist auch die
millionenmetropole sydney von
überschwemmungen betroffen die behörden
riefen rund 60.000 menschen dazu auf
ihre häuser zu verlassen und sich in
sicherheit zu bringen für einen rund
2000 kilometer langen küstenstreifen im
bundesstaat new south wales wurde
außerdem flutwellen alarm ausgegeben
bislang kamen mindestens 20 menschen
infolge der unwetter ums leben
am 8 märz 1917 begann die russische
revolution in sankt petersburg mit
protesten streiks und demonstrationen
von dabei viele frauen die revolution
leitete das ende des russischen
zarenreichs 1
105 jahre später schaut die welt wieder
nach russland an diesem weltfrauentag
und auch morgen für heute sagen wir
danke dass sie dabei waren in diesem
heute schon mal 00 uhr 35 gibt's dann
unser heute-journal update mit wulf
schmiese von uns beiden guten abend
[Musik]
guten abend weil das hoch etwas weiter
nach osten zieht kommen wir auf die
wärmere südwestseite und das merken wir
eigentlich nur daran dass es in
westdeutschland ein bisschen milder wird
heute nacht ist es meist klar und
höchstens in mecklenburg vorpommern
bildet sich auch mal nebel die
temperaturen sinken an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee und am niederrhein auf
1 grad sonst wird es überall frostig mit
minus 2 bis minus zehn grad unter dem
kältesten wird es zwischen dem
berchtesgadener land und dem allgäu mit
minus zehn grad und morgen erwarten uns
dann 7 grad an der ostsee 9 grad sind es
in den mittelgebirgen meist aber gibt es
zweistellige plusgrade und am mildesten
wird sie am niederrhein mit 15 grad und
auch morgen strahlt wieder die sonne und
es gibt nur ganz wenige wolken bei einem
leichten bis mäßigen wind aus östlichen
bis südöstlichen richtungen an diesem
wetter erinnert sich auch am donnerstag
und am freitag wenig am niederrhein wird
sogar noch ein bisschen milder mit bis
zu 17 grad am samstag werden die wolken
dann von westen etwas dichter es bleibt
aber noch trocken und jetzt schauen wir
noch mal ganz woanders hin nämlich auf
die südhalbkugel da geht ja zurzeit
gerade der sommer zu ende und immer im
februar ist die eisbedeckung in der
antarktis minimal sie sehen hier dieser
roten linie die durchschnittliche
eisbedeckung der jahre 1991 bis 2020 in
diesem februar
2022 gab es deutlich weniger ice nämlich
27 prozent weniger das hat der
europäische klimawandel dienst
kopernikus herausgefunden guten abend